Okay, final quiz.
What I've got here is a list of potential reasons why the dynamic parallel version of quicksort
ends up more efficient than the CPU-controlled one.
We've got more efficient partitioning of the data inside the sort.
We've got launching on the fly from the GPU rather than returning to the CPU to do the launch.
Simpler code, because the code is a lot shorter and easier to write,
and greater GPU utilization.
Remember, that GPU utilization is making sure that
as much of GPU is busy doing useful work at any given time.
So as long as you've got enough threads going on at one time to keep the GPU busy, you have high utilization.
So check all the boxes that apply.